several volcanoes around the world are
being woken up on purpose
the mission
to use volcanic eruptions to protect the
earth from global warming
in what ways could you activate a
volcano
how could you do it in the safest way
possible
and would this save the planet or
create more climate chaos
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we woke up volcanoes to fight
climate change
so
how exactly are erupting volcanoes
supposed to stop climate change
well that's simple volcanoes would limit
the amount of sunlight reaching the
earth through a process called solar
geoengineering
yeah you'd purposely pump millions of
tons of sulfur dioxide straight into the
atmosphere
this is the pinatubo strategy
it's named after the 1991 eruption of
mount pinatubo in the philippines
this eruption cooled the planet by about
0.5 degrees and this cooling effect
lasted for one year
that's because sulfuric acid droplets
mixed with moisture and formed aerosols
in the stratosphere
and those aerosols reflected sunlight
away from the earth's surface
while this wouldn't have any effect on
reducing greenhouse gas emissions it
could help slow the melting of
permafrost
now would this be a practical step to
saving the planet or would you end up
endangering billions of people
if you figured out how to control and
trigger not one but many volcanic
eruptions worldwide you could be sitting
on a golden ticket to solving our global
warming problems
hopefully this goes without saying but
however you'd make this happen
it shouldn't be with a nuclear explosion
yeah a nuke could trigger the eruption
you're looking for but it would add a
terrifying dimension of atomic fallout
you wouldn't be able to drill down into
the magma chamber either
that would be like trying to bleed to
death from a paper cut
you'd need to find a volcano that is
ready to erupt and it should be one that
doesn't erupt frequently so there's
pressure building up
you'd want a lot of pressure
now to speed up the process you could
mine some rocks off the top of the
volcano
that way all that pressure could make
the magma blow the weakened rock surface
sky-high
or if you'd prefer a quicker fix
you could place a bunch of explosives
across the top and boom
the only problem would be timing
we still can't accurately predict how
long it takes between the trigger of an
eruption and the actual eruption
but let's assume you did trigger the
volcano and your timing is just right
and now it's time to send those hot
volcanic gases up in the air
i hope you picked the right volcanoes
for this mission you'd want eruptions
that would occur closest to the
stratosphere
this varies depending on latitude
and you'd want to consider other factors
like air circulation patterns and the
amount of sunlight reflected by the
earth's surface
and if you want the eruptions to have
the same effect as pinatubo
you'd need them to be big
or
bigger
this is because the impact of volcanic
eruptions on our global temperature
decreases the more the atmosphere is
warming
scientists think this is because global
warming affects the height of the
stratosphere
the more severe the effects of global
warming
the higher the volcanic plumes would
need to climb
pittetubo scored a six on the volcanic
explosivity index
we'd need an eruption of that or higher
maybe like the 1815 eruption of tambora
in indonesia
or the super eruption of yellowstone
over half a million years ago
those scored seven and eight on the
index
but eruptions of these sizes
anywhere near populated areas
would have devastating effects
we'd have to evacuate people and
resettle them elsewhere
even with every precaution taken
many people could still die
and
even though you woke up a volcano to
fight climate change
you could end up having to deal with
some climate effects you didn't intend
when pinatubo erupted it disrupted the
monsoon season in asia
who knows what kind of unexpected
disaster your eruption would cause
for example rainfall could increase or
decrease dramatically and this would
disrupt the agricultural industry and
result in food shortages around the
globe
then if you did cool down the earth
significantly the temperatures could
jump back to where they were once the
eruption stopped and this could cause
termination shock and devastate wildlife
struggling to adapt to new conditions
okay but what if you managed to avoid
all these adverse side effects and set
off numerous remote active volcanoes
that didn't hurt anybody
well then you could change the course of
rising global temperatures on earth
one eruption similar to pinatubo would
lower the sea surface temperatures by
0.15
to 0.3 degrees
and this effect could last anywhere
between 5 and 20 years
and you wouldn't have to worry too much
about all these eruptions adding more
carbon dioxide to the atmosphere
volcanic eruptions around the world are
estimated to release about 0.26 gigatons
per year
meanwhile global road transportation
alone released
5.8 gigatons of carbon dioxide in the
year
2015. so your genius plan to cool the
earth would have a significantly smaller
carbon footprint than you think
but there's bound to be a better method
to all this madness than triggering
synchronized volcanic eruptions around
the planet
maybe you could lower global
temperatures by
re-freezing the arctic
but
that sounds like a story
for another what if